hi everyone I'm Evan I'm here with Max
and we're here to break down the new
breath of the wild sequel trailer also
talked about any details we may have
noticed or theories that we have so
let's take a look at the trailer alright
so the first thing we see here are these
green strands for rising upwards
definitely not chica riding but more
likely Gerudo right before the scene
changes we see a little bit of words
forming on the top right here I looked
it up to the Gerudo inscriptions and it
looks like at least the first letter is
s upside down and the last letter is L
it's kind of hard to tell but it looks
like e a between so it's probably seal
but we'll go more into the Gerudo stuff
later in the video alright so here we
see some cave paintings this is most
likely Ganondorf possibly demise but
most likely Ganondorf he's he's been
known to will to try it in the past
no snow tably with like pig Ganon or
even in Ocarina of Time actually he had
I tried it on the horse but he's also
leading an army archers in the back it's
hard to tell what species they are so
it's like I can't really say much at
this point on what's exactly happening
in this in a scene in this shot
specifically I noticed that there are
repeating symbols along this strain
that's going upwards a couple times so
we doubt that it's just some random
design but it's some kind of spell
coming from the hand that's holding this
evil entity down here we finally did get
our first look at Zelda looks like she's
on what I thought was some sort of like
ox or something like that but I don't
there's no creature in breath the wild
one that looks like this so who knows
what this is yeah breath of the wild in
terms of like its animal life there
aren't a lot of like really huge animals
yeah that was kind of reserved in terms
of like the scope for the guardians like
you saw a guardian it was like this big
scary thing but it turns like actual
wildlife there really wasn't anything
like this so I'm curious to see outside
of horses like how these are
incorporated its knowledge is world yeah
probably just a new species we haven't
seen yet I mean obviously our gonna have
new content in it so that one person for
sure one thing to know here is these
luminous stones or what what we think is
luminous stones it's actually a big
a key factor in this and I thought
luminous don't you look in the
description in breath of the wild one
they say that in the description is it
holds the souls of the Dead so this cave
is full of them so I'm sure that this
has some sort of reference to like an
undead area or just like a grave in
general something like that alright so
this is our first look at a close look
at the heroes Zelda and link one thing
to note here and the first couple of
frames you see lower on links belt and
there's no Sheik asleep yes so those are
probably gone
so no magnesia snow stasis no bombs what
are they gonna do about that I have no
idea if you're if you can't make sheikah
bombs cuz you need to Chico Slade I
believe to do those we go back to
regular bombs who knows maybe we'll see
the return of like normal Zelda items
quote-unquote yeah possibly
and then of course Zelda's short hair
it's great I love it and then also one
thing is the clothing that is a mixture
of the Hylian tunic and the champions
tunic yeah it's it's interesting because
prior link would wear that hood with the
champions tunic right in some of the
promotional material and I like using
that look as well in the game but yeah
now he's got like new shoulder pads and
it looks like he's got more armor yeah
I'm diggin it it looks really cool yeah
no it look it looks really nice and even
Zelda with her hood now as well we see a
shot here of them drinking water one
thing I like to note in all of breath
world even another Zelda su but
prominently in breath of the wild one is
a Miyazaki references I'm sure that the
producers and directors over there have
watched vault Miyazaki stuff cuz there's
some heavy influences in my opinion that
I've seen this is like straight out of
castle on the sky yeah and a lot of
people have pointed out that link in the
champions tunic looks a lot like the
protagonists from Princess Mononoke yep
yeah there's a lots of references and
crossovers and I've seen and actually
the next scene after this
is pretty much straight out approaches
wondering okay like the tentacles that
come out of the demons and prints
Mononoke when they trying to kill
ashitaka i mean that looks almost
exactly lucky and it's killing this rat
poor rat yeah well the rats run away
well didn't Oh No okay all right this
scene they're trying to cross a bridge
but the animal seems stuck they probably
leave it behind these bridge posts look
kind of like mid to helmets but I don't
know it's kind of a long shot uh another
closer look at Lincoln Zelda here
nothing much to say about this shot
besides she does get surprised and Linc
looks at her so what I might be thinking
here is she knows something that he
doesn't cuz he doesn't seem surprised
yeah that's good catch all right so this
is our first closer look at this evil
form coming from the middle of the
screen two theories here so he's got the
Super Saiyan 3 hair he's cut the
loincloth he's got teeth I don't know if
that's much of a big factor here but um
it from first blush it looks like demise
yeah my original theory was that this
was demise because I couldn't think of
any scenarios or any games I should say
bruh Ganon had that long of hair and the
first person I thought of with long hair
was demise and we mentioned earlier
about the Trident of demise which is
only in Hyrule warriors so maybe they're
adding some of those ideas from Hyrule
warriors into this case it's entirely
possible but again that game isn't canon
so they might just be pulling stuff out
of out of thin air most likely looking
at this now it's Ganon there's a couple
factors here this chest injury is very
very closely related to the end of
Twilight Princess and ended Twilight
Princess again and had that injury right
in the middle of his chest were linked
stabbed him and then even after that for
more proof the way this entity wakes up
is with a neck snap and how he was
finally killed in Twilight Princess was
with Zant neck snapping him or at least
figuratively so there's a lot of
Twilight Princess references in this in
the scene yeah absolutely
if you look at the timeline if you look
at the child timeline it does go ocarina
Majora's Mask Twilight Princess and Four
Swords Adventures right
potentially this game so it's entirely
possible that that's the timeline they
are going down and they're taking stuff
from all those games I just listed if we
are truly going down a child timeline it
does make sense like what the whole
arbiters grunts everything it is in the
Gerudo desert they have Gerudo logos all
over this this form in the earrings and
the loincloth it just seems to add up to
feel like it should be Ganon but you
know let's talk about this hand
yeah like is it infusing this character
with the malice is and I know you like
it looks like the malice is coming out
so it's like what exactly is that hand
my theory it's a seal holding down this
this evil entity but the mouse is still
coming through but who knows link is
putting his hand up here my thoughts on
this I think this look at his hand right
here it might be a part of the mechanics
of the next game since there's no Chico
slate this could be part of his new
thing you might be able to like have
some skills with it who knows so maybe
this is the new kind of power in a sense
that's being utilized by the world
whether it be Gerudo or something
different is yet to be seen but it's
possible that instead of sheikah
technology we'll be seeing this notable
thing about like the scenes with like
the hand and the hand holding and like
saving each other these shots seem are
more than sure they're out of order this
is like a flashback moment of things
going on probably the first shot was
this of them probably entering this
shrine or dungeon or whatever this yeah
to me that that actually looks a lot
like it could be a dungeon just the way
that it's designed and the door is
shaped it seemed like this is the grand
opening to something bigger and I think
that was one of the things that brought
the wild one people were complaining
about was like there's no proper dungeon
it's also possible that like this is
underneath Hyrule Castle so it's like
it's actually highly probable because in
the last shot it seems like at the
moment this entity wakes up then it
reacts to the castle it's probably
deeper underneath the castle right so
that just leads to the question like
what is this thing doing under hyrule
castle like how deep underground does
this go we know that the guardians and
even the divine beast were discovered
under
because breath of the wild takes place
about 10,000 years after the last zelda
game on whatever timeline you choose to
put it on so I think it's interesting
maybe we'll learn more about the history
of like this Hyrule like what really is
hidden underground and like what secrets
are there to be unfolded in the breadth
of the wild universe I got a shot here
of this hand bringing link upwards so
this also kind of cut back on my theory
where I thought this hand would be links
hand from the shot earlier but obviously
it's a separate entity so not quite sure
what this is yet another thing to note
here that I saw is are these eyes of
malice are the same that you shoot in
breath the wild one you know mostly
surrounding like Hyrule Castle but like
little patches of malice here and there
around the world you shoot them and
they'll usually make the mouse go away
if these eyes are still there after
Ganon's gone maybe this was a source the
mouths before Ganon was banished away or
whatever happened to him yeah in breath
of the wild he was kind of hibernating
to reincarnate is this maybe where it
was coming from we get our first wide
shot of Hyrule Field one thing I want to
note here it's during Twilight I
confirmed this in the game is not the
morning this is not a morning shot this
is definitely Twilight time which is the
exact same time that final boss fight in
Twilight Princess happened so this just
adds up to be more twilight princess
references the same thing with links
chica sleep being gone
there is simply no Chicot technologies
there's no towers there are no shrines
which is I can clearly see and breath
the wild one right now that this riot is
there at the bottom right but not in
breath of the wild two non breath of the
wild - it looks like in the true ending
of breath the wild one they said that
you know like the divine be span route
oh stop responding after the defeat
again in so who knows what happens in
that technology but it's clearly gone
it's not not there anymore so as the
castle starts to shake it moves upwards
breath of the wild in space yet breath
the well of the space who knows it could
go just up several thousand feet up into
the air like a just another tower it
could just get into a bigger castle yeah
again like all the castle on the sky I
love you too or you know even Skyward
Sword it could just go straight into the
sky who knows what's gonna happen or it
could be like Howl's Moving Castle it
could be a moon cat it could be yeah
Gate legs are walking more miyazaki
references yes the director of breath of
the wild who's also coming back for
breath of the wild to is also the
director of Skyward Sword maybe has some
sort of affinity towards the Skyward
Sword storyline he set up in that game
and wants to kind of flesh it out a
little bit more now that they're doing
breath of the wild - and hopefully
because they're doing breath of the wild
- that could put a little bit more
emphasis on the story which was one of
my biggest gripes of the first game yeah
I think though that they're taking a lot
of the input from the last game so
hopefully they'll be dungeons hopefully
there'll be a much more fleshed out
story hopefully can pet dago's yeah
that'd be nice that would be nice yeah I
said of just feeding them mean can I
just pet the dog but yeah hopefully
they'll address on those issues coming
into this game because there's a lot
that I wanted even though this game was
very flushed out when I first saw this
trailer I was actually flipping out I
was like jumping out of my chair because
I freaking love this game um I don't
think anybody expected a new breath of
the wild so quickly no absolutely not
and I think we could probably make some
comparisons to Majora's Mask and I
believe was a wind waker - Phantom
Hourglass
yeah Phantom Hourglass takes place
immediately after the Wind Waker when
they're sailing away from outside island
but yeah to be to be sure with it Zelda
does not make proper sequels very often
yeah and it's really interesting a lot
of times Nintendo with a lot of their
games just moves on to the next game
doesn't continue on with the assets that
they currently have so it's cool to see
them doing this now with breath of the
wild continuing that story using these
same assets that got them critical
praise when the game came out back in
2017 if it ain't broke don't fix it
exactly
yeah I mean we look I mean I personally
I break this game that is
my main thing I love to do I love to do
combat stuff so I hope to keep a similar
at least the same engine I want to see
how this how these flights turned out I
think that if they are keeping the same
engine and they are just kind of like
focusing on like the sequel aspects I
think it's pretty safe to say that we'll
see like the same inventory system the
same item break ability system I hope so
I mean of course they want to you know
have a little bit of an evolution in the
actual engine itself and in short I want
a little bit of growth but also keep it
little bit of the same yeah absolutely I
think it'll be a little bit more than
what Majora's Mask was to ocarina of
time as Majora's Mask was pretty much
exactly the same in terms like the
inventory system right breath of the
while - we'll probably have some new
mechanics here and there I think that's
safe to say
but I guess time will tell how that will
go yep so that was our little trailer
analysis Theory breakdown of the new
sequel trailer for The Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild thanks so much for
joining us
[Music]
you
[Music]